I've had it I've been here 7 years we
don't have a budget we haven't had one
since the mid '90s it was pretty much
fairly obvious that we were going to get
to something like this like having
McCarthy out altogether I think is the
surprise but like the fight that was
going to brew between these guys was was
very very obvious all along uh here's
Matt Gates yesterday explaining why he
did what he did I mean the speaker did
not just fail to remediate the breach of
the agreement with he made with us in
January he accelerated the instances of
breach like after I laid out the breach
he went and violated the 72-hour rule
after I laid out the breach he violated
the 100 million uh no Amendment
suspension rule so he he seems to to be
reverting to the very unfortunate muscle
memory of Washington DC that has put our
nation a top of $33 trillion debt that
has led to you know two trillion annual
deficits in our near future and the
rapid Global dollarization of the
economy you look at the brick system you
know Brazil Russia India China South
Africa they're moving away from the
dollar and just in August they added six
new countries including G20 country uh
economies in the Western Hemisphere and
Gulf monarchies moreover you've se you
saw us news say that the number one
economic trend of 2023 is dollarization
globally this worries me you all get all
worked up that there's going to be some
uncomfortable chaotic moment that I'll
feel pressure from conserv Or democrats
or whomever I feel the Judgment of
History I feel the weight of that I
worry that when the history books are
written about this country going down
that my name is going to be on the board
of directors here and if this country is
going down and if we're losing the
dollar I am going down fighting and I
don't care if that means fighting
Republicans Democrats the uni party the
leadership the packs the lobbyists I've
had it I've been here seven years we
don't have a budget we haven't
had one since the mid90s I am through
with it I apologize for using that word
but the only path forward here is to
have single subject spending bills that
can be reviewed amended considered and I
think that is the responsible way that
our legislators all over this country
operate for good reason the colorful
language notwithstanding you have to I
think really agree with the heart of
what he is saying we are going into debt
we are printing money we pass bills that
make no sense that no one reads
how about just single line item bills do
you think this is a good policy yes or
no do like let's really know what does
funding Ukraine have to do with funding
our border and trust me those are just
like the two like most obvious examples
the nonsensical things we literally fund
gender studies in Pakistan and all the
rest of the craziness okay you still
you're into that one I don't know why
why he's into that one anyway uh I
personally I agree with the heart of all
of that and he's saying I will stand up
for what's
right